what's all about community because it's
community has morphed over the years
it's had this great transformation it
becomes it's very creative show and it
bears little resemblance from sort of
where it started off now yeah it's like
a snake we just slough off skin every
once in a while we leave it behind and
then there's a new snake yeah no we were
canceled by NBC I don't know if you've
ever experienced with that but what
smooth sailing with that great great and
we then Yahoo bought us for two billion
dollars and Wow incredible it's the
terrible deal look at that check again
yeah and they they were they they let us
they let Dan Harmon do anything right
and and it was it was a great season
there was no notes there was no
commercials and it was it was terrific
and every end we got paget Brewster and
Keith David and they were amazing so
that and we don't know what the ratings
are right but Yahoo just goes we would
like to they want to do more which says
all right well then what where I don't
think we are unless they pay me a lot of
money because what can you do with two
billion great I need I'm building evil
lair no I think I think we will do a
movie if Dan will write the scripts so I
think
I'd love to do another appear that's
indicative of the journey that this show
oh this is normal yeah it's very
run-of-the-mill normal standard boring
sitcom yeah
this list it's yeah it's basically
there's not much happens you'll see take
a look
imagine the times we all get in together
especially when I use my powers to help
solve all your problems
[Laughter]
we just finished year six and it was
hard work and I don't want to care about
Greendale and I don't want to spend my
brief moment of humanity doing
conceptual risks developing the
imaginary TV show of our lives by the
way
terrible improv Ice Cube head you were
just looking at your drink
[Applause]